white smiths welcome to the forge
eric good to see you good to see you
jesse you've tallied up a total of 40
000
and if you win out you stand a chance at
taking home 50 000
but eric if you came out on top that's
your first glad of the forge win and
you'll get a five thousand dollar check
and we'll ask if you want to come join
us in the final battle of this
competition series you're gonna be
building this
the echinaceas
the aegonacs traces its origin back to
the first millennium bc all across the
mediterranean region
this deadly double-edged dagger was used
by roman gladiators in pairs allowing
them to deliver quick slashes and deadly
strikes upon opponents inside the walls
of the coliseum
this weapon was so fierce it was even
believed to have been wielded by mithras
the persian god of the sun
now along with the weapon we have also
chosen the forge welding technique that
we want you both to use to build your
blades now if you look at the pantry
you'll see we have stacks of 1095 and 15
n20 high carbon steel bars
we want you to take that steel and turn
it into at least 100 layer twisted
damascus billet from which you will make
your blades so work hard stay sharp your
time starts now i always have the
tendency to pick too much material at
the beginning so
i set four layers off to the side that
leaves me with 20 layers which means i
have to cut and restack five pieces to
get 100 layers
so now that my billet is drawn out
come on i need to get this thing cut
into five pieces jesse's not a big guy
so i wonder how difficult it's gonna be
for him to actually twist this hot steel
okay let's see how well this works step
on the plate stand on those you're
helping anchor it and you got better
leverage yeah good enough for me
i already have my blade mostly forged to
shape and i get ready for the quench
if this quench fails could send me home
and end my wintry
here we go jesse is now in the oil
that's great
one perfectly the blade looks great
there's no cracks i heard no pings
things have been going great in this
round so far so now i need to make an
anthropomorphic handle so i grab some
mild steel it'll be a lot lighter in the
end rather than brass
okay
my blade looks menacing it looks
terrifyingly sharp the grind lines are
pretty much perfect and then my handle
is just a person
[Music]
it's kind of great
i'm going to use 22 pieces draw it out
split it into five pieces restack it and
draw it again that'll put me at 110
layers i'm scared that once i start
twisting i'm just gonna see layers start
pulling apart
if this fails there's no way i'm gonna
come back to win this challenge
oh yeah everything on my steel looks
good it's time to throw it in the oil
oh there you go all right we've got two
quench blades colors in that blade look
pretty good when you put it in the oil i
got a good solid blade here some days i
even amazed myself my sword it's gotten
a lot lighter and i want to make sure i
leave that tang a little on the heavy
side and bring that balance back a
little closer to the handle now it's
time to get this handle glued up his
little man
the rest of the time i have left is
devoted to sharpening this blade i
couldn't be happier with the way this
blade's turning out five
four
three
two
one vice miss put down your tools this
round is over blaze miss welcome to our
strength test today we have the roman
throne chop
and since you didn't get a chance to
pick the technique or the weapon you get
to choose who goes first
what
i'll take it
all right eric you want to go first
let's do it bud
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
all right eric i gotta say good job man
all right first of all there's no
deflection deformation it came out nice
did a good job
if we could etch this thing for like
another two hours this thing would be
amazing looking but the one complaint i
have is there is a ton of weight on here
controlling that during chops it rolled
over on me a couple times other than
that
good job thank you
all right jesse you're up you're ready
to go
head no
well we're gonna do it anyway
i can tell that the purpose of this
chair is to destroy blades
it's been such a long road but this this
could be the beginning of the end i may
not be here for the next battle
[Music]
all right jesse nice job it's nice and
light
it did a good job on the throne the edge
is fine everything's still tight and
true
good job thank you
gladiators of the forge this is it this
is the sharpness test
i'm gonna take your weapons and try to
cut through these ropes
eric your first you ready for this let's
do it though let's do it
[Music]
damn
better
all right alex talk about your sword
here you have a sharp edge
but there is a weight to your weapon
that makes it hard to hold on to it did
cut most of the ropes but overall
it will cut
[Music]
jesse your turn you ready
sure all right let's do it
so
all right jesse let's talk about your
weapon here first up your edge cut most
of the rope except for the last one
but i cut a different angle so i'll call
that on me
but it is sharp what i love about this
is the balance and weight you have on
your weapon overall it will cut
now guys both of your blades perform
extremely well during our test which
makes for a very difficult decision for
our judges so now they have to decide
which one of you is taking home that 5
000 check and the title of gladiator of
the forge jesse if you win that's seven
total wins and forty five thousand
dollars in your pocket
eric if you came out on top that's your
first glad of the forge win in a
redemption round and you'll get a five
thousand dollar check and we'll ask if
you wanna come join us in the final
battle of this competition series our
judges did make a final decision
gentlemen
the gladiator of the forge today is
jesse congratulations you did it again
man
eric
it's been an honor to watch you work but
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut by the smallest of margins and
jay's gonna tell you why it basically
just came down to weight there was so
much weight in that handle it made it
harder to control and that's the reason
we're sending you home
i get it i get it at least i made you
guys work for it this time
jesse that is seven battles and seven
victories you just won another check for
five thousand dollars well done
you now have 45 000 in your pocket and
you are seven titles in with a chance
for one more if you have enough in you
to go back in the forge and battle again
what do you say
yeah
fantastic i can see the finish line why
not keep going
what just happened i'm somehow the seven
time gladiator of the forge
awesome man well congratulations again
we can't wait to see you battle it out
in the final battle well done man
i keep on saying that this battle is
closer than my previous battle i can't
imagine a scenario in which it'll be
closer for the next battle i never
expected to be fighting for the last 5
grand to 50 grand but i'm going to keep
my place on the throne
you